let me ask you something you and i have
both worked at starnout live
and i'm curious because everyone tells
me
when i was when i was at shout out live
i wasn't one of those quiet writers i i
would i like to
sort of get up and perform my ideas for
people you know i was i was the guy that
was always talking
and i've heard that you were the same
way that you like to when you had an
idea
and you wanted to make a comedy pitch
that you could make everybody in the
room laugh is that true
yeah man because you know we we have
that stand-up mentality now some people
came in
the show of course as straight writers
and some came in as stand-up artists we
are used to being
in front of our audience we're used to
projecting a certain way and we lose to
we like to paint pictures of what we're
pitching so that was my style
you know what i'd love to hear about us
i love to hear about the ideas that
never made it
onto cern those are my favorite ideas do
you have any pitches
that you did back in the day that you
loved and you got up and you performed
them and it never got on the show
oh yeah man i had a bunch of them man i
had one this one i loved
this one i understand why i didn't make
it but this is one of my favorite ones
so i had a guy that that used to work in
a bank
used to bring the pillow for years years
doing bank teller
like when you work somewhere you you you
start to take on
your job your job becomes a part of you
because you go there every day you're
doing it every day
it's a bank teller you count money you
lick the thumb
look at something you count the money
out right make sure the person is good
you know
if you don't have one little round
circle sponges that you put your
thumbnails yeah but anyway
most people are so used to counting
money yeah and they give you that money
for you make that money all out for you
right so this guy ends up getting fired
right from the bank
he moved on he was there for a long time
he ended up getting a new job
now he works at a sandwich shop now but
he's working at a sandwich shop like
subway or something like that
but he can't get the bank teller out of
his system so he's making you a sandwich
you want the club sandwich you know the
club sandwich comes with the cookie the
bacon
coming to the the turkey the swiss
you want that right and he actually you
want swiss cheese on it
and he lifts his face
[Laughter]
i love that idea that didn't get on the
air
you know look at your thumb making a
sandwich with somebody that's gonna be
that should have made it what else you
got another one i wanna hear another one
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i got
you on man uh uh i got one oh oh oh oh
this one right here never made it
this was uh tom brady the quarterback
tom brady
uh who used to play for the patriots now
plays for the temple big buccaneers
this guy he was like he was the guest
house he was a guest host
and uh he came to the show and i wrote
this idea for him where he was the
first player in the nfl to smack another
man on the butt
after a good play oh man it was but this
was a throwback like to the 40s
yeah in the days when guys were 11
helmets yeah yeah he just kept
smacking guys on the ass after a good
play second one yeah
i'm expecting an ass after a good play
but nobody understood why this guy was
doing this
[Laughter]
why did he keep smacking people on the
butt no one understood why he kept doing
it
so he was the only nfl player in the
world who got traded to every team
in the nfl because one understood what
the hell he was doing
when he started doing it in the shower
that's when it took
that's when it went up to another level
yeah yeah that's a very funny idea i
can't believe i
think i think it's a good sketch that's
a great sketch idea are you kidding me
there's a million of them that should
have made it and i just don't you know
but you know
i digress man it's all good i guess you
don't care they didn't get on the show
but look at you now you're in your zen
space i love this place you're happy